oggi ragazzi mi sono seduto no mi ha
detto cazzo domenica quindi devo fare è
pippo ho avuto un momento interiore in
cui sono morto dentro sono resuscitato e
ho detto va a fan culo a questo gioco
oggi non giochiamo a david mills perché
voglio buttare la mia vita in un altro
modo di tel aviv i ragazzi per momento
che sono video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
su ai experiment che significa aiuto non
so piu voglia di giocare è più vis
experiment prima inter agazzi è un sito
che racchiude un sacco di applicazioni
strane robe [ __ ] che avevo già giocato
forse tempo fa però diciamo che ce ne
sono talmente tante che potrei farlo
all'infinito la cosa [ __ ] che giorgio
cam grazie giorgio maria chiara su sto
giocando le acque
ho capito cosa devo fare
devono cliccare questo tasto qui io mai
e casadio
questa è una bassa 5 punti mi sembra un
altro inquinamento ha detto è tornato
normale io faccio le foto alle cose che
le riconosce o che figata assurda per
comando il pd a capirlo nautica
technology di sfortuna bergamasco mar ma
che cazzo blair allora altra roba
vediamo se conosce proprio tutto tutto
il circostante eccolo qua
cos'è questa roba zio qui è grazie
che cosa dunque l'ultima rampa che prova
a far indovinare ragazzi solo per capire
se stesse il siero ci fa e questo dà
forza
no non è un microfono e un parco angulo
zio va bene così basta grazie giorgio va
bene ragazzi questo era giorgio che han
belli ottimo cioè non avevo idea o al
meglio la happy with forse auto drug
test è roba ma perché ci sono tutti i
giochi fighissimi che avevamo messo per
tobia stato drowning cosa devo fare
disegno la pizza una pizza blu perché mi
piacciono le pizze al gruppo che vediamo
se c'è la pizza si cela pizza grazie a
pd tutti segni una cosa e lui tela
migliora tipo questo è un uccello per me
esatto bravo madonna come intuitivo
questo gioco facciamo una faccia ok una
faccia normale mio come la disegna lui
meraviglioso è il gioco dell'anno
dell'anno proviamo a disegnare quindi fa
vigenti allora e sono sicuro che avrai
il compilatore giusto per per me ci
siamo ragazzi e fatemi capire un attimo
cosa perfetto perfetto era esattamente
quello che pensavo cervello perché
ovviamente sinonimo di fa vj poi
cervello
sì ma quindi scusami se uno vuole fare
un disegno veramente suo vanificata e
barca barca prima faretta avete vedere
se riesco a fare una roba decente tipo
così ok
sì però a livello di oggetto ci sono un
paio di problemi ecco perché queste già
meglio facciamo uno squalo che arriva e
ti distrugge la barca vediamo se riesco
a farlo vedere
perfetto sicuramente vi intuire anche
questo è uno squalo va bene close enough
no non è esattamente quello che stavo
pensando
va bene lo stesso a quickdraw mica
grazie a dio che ti trovo conoscevo
purtroppo perché sarò veramente triste
disegniamo nascere le facciamo un giro
anche di chi non può essere le palle
perché utilizzata giocasta roba come
un'ascia raga non ne ho idea o epub
forse boss caracas all'odio già mi dava
sti caxxi mile high city ma si vede che
un'ascia va bè ragazzi quindi dovrò da
parte facciamo un'altra roba
the infinite drum machine verso della
mucca a sono suoni tutte ste cose ma che
storia nord è più giusto trovando ok ho
scelto di giovani che facciamo noi
ragazzi kinue che charlie charles
possono accompagnare solo a me era una
cosa un po da decerebrati questa però
era giusto apposta per me drau together
vita a neutral network
ok devo disegnare questa roba qui cosa
mi sto facendo fa è un fiore un ho
capito ho capito è una pala e cioè
praticamente gli ordigni una roba e lui
mi dice come continuare per per
disegnare un mulino alla facciamo prima
questo per continuano too much ha
piegato è vero avevo di segnare solo
questo disegno un pene vediamo come velo
completato alimentare un mulino esatto
era un mulino a forma di pene che storia
fantastico ragazzi devo averlo non c'era
il suggeritore anche partito i compiti
di matematica ma c'è un'altra roba
facciamo un una fascia ok parti ad
insegnarmi una faccia da questo va bene
disegna mi lo yoga per che cosa cosa
amica disegno per lo yoga ti piace
lo so che ti piace e uomo questo ci
faccia anche il tappetino guarda è
talmente perfetto che ha detto che va
bene così vabbè proviamo a fare solo
così vediamo come lo continua casa qual
è la tua idea di yoga esattamente
fratello school che sarebbe teschio
facciamo al teschio school model però un
fucile cara e inquietante stava passare
la zecca harlow c'era solo così con
qualche acido di troppo però era un
teschio zio mano proviamo a mano da da
una roba del genere vai bisogna mila
mano da questo
mano a mano di chernobyl zio cos'è sta
roba
completano il disegno geniale sta roba
pre ombre sono una ruota della
bicicletta è però dai micro un pò ci
arriva e cioè la cosa è abbastanza
inquietante ragazzi prima fare solo il
manubrio ellis è la è la cosa più
schifosa che abbia mai visto però ha
capito che quale il manubrio cioè
geniale è sta roba cosa cazzo è un club
rabbit facebook è un granchio coniglio
con la faccia da maiale cosa dovrebbe
essere un club rabbit facebook
ok va bene bellissimo ho capito che la
faccia di un porco ma non ho capito il
resto a ragazzi giochi moderni quanto mi
piacciono quanto li adoro cose ai due
fai un duetto con l'intelligenza
artificiale praticamente un piano che ti
risponde va bene basta che mi insegna
anche
sì però devi stare calmo faccio io anche
[Musica]
va bene ma se fai le ultime cose che ho
fatto io non vale era come a scuola che
la frase finale
la devi farlo
[Musica]
porca eva
ma mi prendi per il culo
va bene un po rincoglionito come piano
però ok se sarò baia poi quanta roba
stupida sto vedendo museo
a devi resistere più tempo possibile a
devo saltare gli ostacoli dato aumenta
il tono di voce quando santo ma chi
cazzo come lega non ha senso pro kei
kagami giura non ho mai giocata roba
così stupida mia vita
chi chi chi fottutamente inventato sto
gioco è la cosa più da celebrolesi che
abbia mai visto a parte gli opportuni
ciardi
non ci sperimentale ed ai quali deve
ovvio almeno quello già fanno cagare si
gioca in una qualità caricamento presumo
che sia un giorno della madonna se meno
carichi così zio un ora per caricare
mica neanche in battlefield ci mettono
ragusa il clic anywhere draghi in corso
cosa sono gli enti and pop the bubble
ma cosa mia domanda domanda posso perché
c'è un tizio che sta parlando di sotto
perché lo scoppiare le bolle perché io
spero la mia vita in questo modo la
meglio è qui va bè ragazzi nell'ultimo
perché questa mia mi attira un botto e
poi e puoi dire basta così per chi è
sotto effetto di lsd questa roba qua va
bene ragazzi e che possono chiudere qui
video di oggi non aveva fortunatamente
senso ma gli e book è partito il pensato
tra l'altro bel ali tomorrowland dai
ragazzi sparare mi sia piaciuto cosa 102
mila persone al momento che mi piace
anche i vari social game iniziali sono
stati semplici prendiamo fossero visti
per ragazzi
[Musica]